الامتثال المكره سابقه تكبدتها اسرائيل
بخضوعها غير المسبوق للمسائله على وقع مضي
100 يوم من حربها الداميه على غزه لم تعتد
تل ابيب ابدا النزول تحت خط المحاسبه بفضل
ستار الحمايه الامريكي والغربي المرخيه
عليها نحو ثمانيه عقود الدعوه التي رفعتها
جنوب افريقيا دون شريك من اشقاء غزه
الاقربين احدثت دويا عالميا وقلقا
اسرائيليا عميقا في اعقاب تاسيس دولتها
ساهمت اسرائيل بحفاوه في تاسيس اتفاقيه
منع الاباده الجماعيه لملاحقه النازيين
لكنها وجدت نفسها اليوم في قفص الاتهام
نفسه الفريق القانوني لجنوب افريقيا خطف
الانظار ليس فقط برمز تاريخ مناهضه بلاده
للعنصريه بل
لمرافعة عرضت اسرائيل غزه لما اعتبرت اكثف
حمله قصف في تاريخ الحروب
المعاصره في 84 صفحه اسست جنوب افريقيا
دعواها غير المسبوقه على ان ممارسات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه طوال نحو
100 يوم تشكل جريمه اباده جماعيه
لارتكابها بالقصد المحدد لتدمير
الفلسطينيين في القطاع والقصد المحدد هو
ما سيكون على ادعاء جنوب افريقيا اثباته
امام المحكمه بالنظر لاتفاقيه منع جريمه
الاباده الجماعيه المعتمده امميا في
التاسع من ديسمبر عام
1948 والتي اشترطت مادتها الثانيه التوفر
الكلي او الجزئي لقصد اباده جماعه ما على
اساس قومي او عرقي او جنسي او ديني
بالاقدام على قتل اعضاء من الجماعه او
الحاق اذى جسدي او روحي خطير باعضاء منها
او اخضاع الجماعه عمدا لظروف معيشيه يراد
بها تدميرها المادي كليا او جزئيا او فرض
تدابير تستهدف الحيلوله دون انجاب الاطفال
داخل الجماعه او نقل اطفال من الجماعه
عنوه الى جماعه اخرى القصد اذا هو شرط
اساسي لاثبات ارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه وهو
ما عززته صحيفه الدعوه مشفوعا بالوقائع مع
الساعات الاولى لمئ يوم من القصف والغارات
قارب عدد ضحاياها 3000 باعتبار ارقام
مطورين تحت الانقاض نزعت تصريحات رسميه
اسرائيليه صفه البشريه عن اهل غزه تمهيدا
لقرار بحصار كامل
قاتل خشم مز لا كهرباء ولا طعام ولا ماء
ولا وقود لقطاع غزه نحن نحارب حيوانات
بشريه هل كان جالانت يقصد افراد المقاومه
فقط يجيب الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتزوج
بعد ايام قليله بان المستهدف كل الشعب في
غزه تلك الامه كلها مسؤوله والقول ان
المدنيين لا صله لهم بالامر محظ افتراء
كان يمكنهم ان يثوروا ويسقطوا ذلك النظام
الشرير في
[موسيقى]
غزه واذا نصت الاتفاقيه على ان اخضاع
الجماعه المستهدفه عمدا لظروف معيشيه تهدف
لتدميرها المادي يعتبر اباده جماعيه فان
قائمه الدلائل تطول كثيرا لتشمل مثالا لا
حصرا استهداف المستشفيات وكل مرافق الحياه
الاساسيه وقصف المناطق الامنه المفترضه
التي دعي المدنيون للنزوح اليها ثم
استهدفوا فيها على مدار يومي الترافع بدا
فريق جنوب افريقيا شديد الثقه في حجته هل
تعتقد شخصيا ان الاسرائيليين يريدون
القضاء على الفلسطينيين في غزه
لم تكن النيه ولا الافعال وحدهما ما
استندت اليه دعوه جنوب افريقيا ولكن ايضا
غياب اي عقاب قضائي او سياسي في اسرائيل
لمرتكبي الاباده الجماعيه او المحرضين
عليها جاءت ردود الفعل الاسرائيليه على
المحاكمه اكثر من غاضبه حتى وصفت تصريحات
المسؤولين في تل ابيب بالتشنج
والتجاوز اي وقاحه هذه نفاق جنوب افريقيا
صارخ
هل من ثمره عاجله
لمقاضاته العدل الدوليه على صعيد الوصول
لادانه بشان الاباده الجماعيه قد يستغرق
الامر سنوات وفق قانونيين لكن جنوب
افريقيا في عريضتها طالبت محكمه العدل بان
تامر اسرائيل بالوقف الفوري لجميع هجماتها
العسكريه التي قد تشكل اباده جماعيه فهل
ستفعل المحكمه وهل تمتثل
اسرائيل